all right for this little meeting of the
Council of geeks I'm gonna do something
a little different you're probably
waiting to see what popular movie or
video game i was going to rip into
instead i'm gonna go the other way i am
going to defend and extol the virtues of
GI joe the rise of cobra now make no
mistake I am NOT going to claim that
this is some sort of misunderstood
classic or great film it's a stupid
movie it's stupid fun here's the thing
though stupid fun is hard to do right
most stupid movies are just stupid and
I'm not even saying it's in a it's a so
bad that it's good movie I think it has
genuine merits it is in that movie
collection you see behind me it is not a
guilty pleasure I will defend it I have
no shame about it a little bit of
context here I'm not about to defend
this movie out of any kind of nostalgia
I didn't grow up on GI Joe I actually
wasn't even allowed to watch it I didn't
have the toys I didn't read the comic
books I have no particular attachment to
GI Joe as a property still love that
movie and here is why it captured for me
perfectly the essence of what happens
when young boys play with action figures
you get two boys anywhere from nine to
twelve you give them some action figures
they start playing with them with each
other and it's going to go something
like this my guys get in the van and
they drive away and we get away from you
oh but my guys have these suits on and
then make them run really fast and I
catch up to your guys in the band oh
yeah well my guys that their van has has
rockets and I shoot them and your guys
oh yeah well what am I guys is a ninja
he could dodge any rockets that you want
now he's on top of your van oh yeah well
the front of my van can transform into a
scoop and now i'm throwing cars backhoe
over the top and at your ninja and it's
that exact feel of one-upsmanship a
ridiculous are you kidding me
one-upsmanship that happens when boys
play with action
figures and I think that experience
reads across the board like I said I
never played with GI Joes but that same
feeling that same feel it's there and I
hope at least that it's still there for
boys who were playing with these toys
that feel it's throughout the whole film
and that is why I was really really
upset when Stephen Sommers was booted
and they brought in somebody else and
they ditch most of the cast and even
though they're technically continuing
the same story it's almost a reboot of
the franchise I get why they're doing it
first one was successful but it wasn't
hugely successful critics didn't like it
most fans didn't like it but there's
there's a feel there and it is a feel I
can't there's if you want to go by
specific merits of what you would
normally call a good film the thing
falls apart it's a mess but there's just
this feeling to it and it's an essence
that I really don't think it is gonna be
captured in the next one it could be
wrong we'll see what happens when it
comes out I'll be there in theaters I
love the first one I'll get the second
one a shot but I just have a feeling
Stephen Sommers brought this feeling to
this movie that we're not going to get
when the sequel rolls out in any case
for right now councils adjourned